За цей єдиний у селі православний храм вже кілька тижнів
сперечаються мешканці Брониці, що на Волині.
У середині січня більшість громади висловилась за приєднання
до новоствореної Православної церкви України.
Вони не стали чекати, поки набуде чинності закон
про зміну підлеглості парафій і взяли храм під свій контроль -
попри протести односельців, які залишились вірними УПЦ  МП
Новий настоятель храму від ПЦУ Олег Мицько
на свій перший молебень у Брониці прийшов не з порожніми руками.
Це є фотокопія оригіналу томоса,
який вже знаходиться у нас в Києві, який дано нашій церкві.
Оце отакий документ. Такий він гарний, великий!
Парафіяни радіють, що їм вдалося відстояти храм у боротьбі
з односельцями, які є прихильниками УПЦ МП.
А староста громади наголошує: йдеться не просто про релігійні вподобання.
Це боротьба іде за Україну: чи буде така держава, чи її не буде.
Останні щупальця - православна церква московська в Україні.
Якщо нам вдасться їх відрубати - повірте:
буде Україна, почнеться Україна.
Під час опитування, яке провели прихильники Православної церкви України,
за вихід з УПЦ МП підписалися 750 жителів Брониці. Проти - 167.
Віряни УПЦ МП відмовились пустити односельців-прибічників ПЦУ до храму.
Сутичок вдалося уникнути лише завдяки поліції.
Зрештою голова сільради опечатав церкву,
а потім активісти просто поміняли замки.
Прихильники Московського патріархату залишились за порогом.
Новий настоятель храму Олег Мицько несправедливості у цьому не вбачає.
Каже: рішення більшості - святе.
Насамперед громада. Громада - це сила.
Якщо вся громада вирішила, або принаймні
її більшість, то воно повинно так і буть.
Я думаю, що в ближчому майбутньому вони перейдуть до нас.
Священик УПЦ МП Сергій Голодюк у церкві тепер персона нон ґрата.
Стосунки між ним і вірянами, які перейшли у ПЦУ - вкрай напружені.
Він і прихильники Московського патріархату змушені
збиратися у приватному приміщенні, що належить одному з прихожан.
Сергій Голодюк веде нас до хати, де
поспіхом облаштували імпровізовану церкву.
Перехід єдиного у селі храму до ПЦУ він називає
рейдерським захопленням, себе - законним керівником приходу,
а вимоги прихильників ПЦУ - нелегітимними.
Вимога була на українській мові читати Євангеліє.
Ще якщо патріарха Кирила можна не поминать,
змиритися з цим, то я не можу читати Євангеліє на українській мові.
Я знаю, як має бути, як церква устроєна,
як богослужіння мають вестися, на якій мові, як воно має бути.
Це ж компетенція священика, а не простих людей, правда?
Відстоювати право Московського патріархату
на храм Сергій Голодюк збирається у суді.
Те, що сільська влада стала на бік активістів,
він називає порушенням конституції.
За його словами, підписи прихильників ПЦУ збирали за допомогою маніпуляцій.
До того ж, стверджує він, багато людей змінили думку:
за УПЦ МП підписалося вже 300 чоловік.
Ці підписи - вони безцінні.
Ці люди подавали інформацію правдиву, усвідомлюючи.
Це люди, які на даний час являються нашими прихожанами.
Щоб вони не казали, що їх там 700, а нас тільки 100.
На перше богослужіння в імпровізованій церкві
зібралися близько 30 мешканців села,
які вирішили залишитись в УПЦ МП.
Прихильників ПЦУ вони вважають розкольниками
і не приховують своєї образи на владу, яка, на їхню думку,
не захистила їхнє право молитися в єдиному сільському храмі.
Якщо брати те, що пише Євангеліє, ми навіть не повинні
спілкуватися з іновірцями, не їсти з ними, не відвідувати їх.
Ми не служимо Росії. Ні руському Богові.
Ми служимо своєму Богові, якому ми вік поклоняємся.
Мої батьки ходили сюди, мої діди ходили сюди.
І я ходила сюди з дитинства.
Важко дивитися на таке, що у нас. Господи, дай,
щоб ми ходили всі в одну церкву…
Тим часом, на своє перше богослужіння збираються мешканці Брониці,
які вирішили приєднатися до новоствореної громади ПЦУ.
Вони радіють можливості молитися українською мовою
і не згадувати московського патріарха.
Настрій у вірян - переможний. Перша літургія для них - справжнє свято.
Вони згадували Кирила. А нащо нам ворог?
Як вони благословляють, хрестять
і посилають танки на нас, на дітей, на онуків - щоб наші гинули діти.
Ми не хочемо московської церкви, ні!
Відтепер ми українська церква.
Ми незалежні від іншої країни, яка є агресором
і не молимось за їхнє військо.
Ніхто їх не виганяв. Вони самі пішли, вони так вирішили, це їхнє право.
Але я думаю, що все буде добре. Ми будемо всі стояти разом у цьому храмі.
Чи об’єднаються обидві частини православної громади
знову в одній церкві - невідомо.
Поки до цього не готова жодна зі сторін.
Молитися у єдиному сільському храмі по черзі вони також не хочуть.